hello I'd like to welcome you to
tonight's chess openings explain class
from the st. Louis chess club my name is
Jim McLaughlin I thought we would start
with Bobby Fischer's favorite opening go
through some of the Rory Lopez main
variations of course he liked the
opening because it gave it's one of the
most complicated openings that Y can
play in the double King pon era opening
and that gave him and other great -
attacking players lots of opportunities
by the same token it's very difficult
opening and black gets plenty of
opportunities for counter-attacks that
make it quite an interesting chess
struggle so here's the opening moves of
course Bishop to b5 is the starting
point for all the Rory Lopez openings
White's idea is to put black Sun or
under pressure by attacking the knight
on c6 which defends the black e5 pawn
which is attacked by the white knight on
f3 so white starts out with the opening
advantage of the first move and he gets
continuing pressure for about 25 to 30
moves depending on the opening variation
chosen we're going to start out with an
old-fashioned opening which with Knight
to f6 which is really called the Berlin
defense but it's going to transpose in a
move or two into the steinitz variation
which was the first rule champion he
used to play this around 1880 and and
after that and then the next world
champion Emanuel Lasker and Jose
Capablanca after him they used to play
this same defense they would play both
sides white or black quite frequently in
their tournaments and match games
so white castle's okay so move for the
d6 move that's the characteristic move
of the steinitz variation the drawback
it the drawback to the move it blocks in
the black Bishop on f8 for a while but
the black has some later maneuvers to
get the bishop to a useful post the
strength of the defences it's a very
straightforward way to protect the pawn
on e5 which the black maintains that
pawn as long as possible and it blocks
the white eforp on and limits White's
attacking chances white naturally plays
d4 right away he wants to force black to
do pawn takes pawn that would give white
up a possibly down the road of playing
'if I've and it would possibly eliminate
the black ePHI pot which would give
White's knights and bishops more scope
black brings this bishop up and breaks
the pin allowing the knight to continue
to defend the e5 pawn white develops his
Knight to c3 and black brings out is
black squared Bishop to e7 you can see
that the both players and this by the
way is the world championship game 11
kapa block is white versus Alaska played
in march 30 1921
so but this game is Alaska as white and
Kappa black is black and it was a draw
anyway you can see that both the
grandmasters every move was a center
pawn are developing the Knights bishops
and then White Castle black will soon
catch up on Castle E white places rook
to e1 to activate the rook after all it
was blocked by the pawn on f2 so it
wasn't doing anything not helps protect
the e4 pawn and black is more or less
forced to do pawn takes pawn at this
point because once that white pawns
defended by the knight on c3 and the
work on e 1 white threatens to take the
knight on c6 and then exchange bonds and
win the pawn on e5 so that's why black
does pawn takes pawn at this point
naturally white takes back black castles
white takes the night with the bishop
giving black double pawns black it takes
with the paw and keeping the bishop on
d7 so as compensation for the double
pawns black does have the two bishops of
course they're fairly inactive at this
point in the game but they give him good
defensive and attacking chances later on
and the double pawns on black side are
not all that weak because they're in
that there's three pawns the two double
bonds with the pawn next to it on d6
that pawn on c6 covers the d5
scorekeeping White's Knight from hopping
into d5 which is quite helpful and the B
file is opened at some point black can
play worth to be eight and attack the b2
pawn and white will either have to play
b3 or work to be one if he plays b3
it'll weaken the black squares a little
bit around his queen side position and
if he plays Rick to b1 he'll put his
rook yet behind a pawn in an inactive
position white develops his Bishop to g5
and black activates his rook from behind
his f7 pawn protecting the bishop and
you can see that the bishop at e7 is
even though it doesn't have any
particularly good moves at this point it
is a good defender it defends the knight
on f6 and allows the knight to move
there is no pin by the white bishop and
the computer says if you look at the
right side of the screen next to move 10
or to e8 the numeric evaluation from the
chess engine commode
which I use is 0.00 so it says it's
completely even at this point in the
game after 10 moves
so anyway white activates his Queen to a
better square moving it to the
third-ranked where it defends the e4
pawn and now White's rooks are
protecting each other and white is
preparing at some point to move his a
work over perhaps the d1 behind the
Queen will see flex going to institute a
standard maneuver in this opening to
deal with the fact that his black
squared bishop on e7 has no moves he
attacks the white bishop forcing it to
basically to retreat white retreats at
age 4 now black jose kappa blanka
retreats the knight - h7 offering to
exchange bishops once that if white
exchanges bishops then a lot of blacks
problems of being cramped are gone and
that bishop that was blocked by the pawn
on d6 is off the board so that problem
is taken care of then it's pretty much
an even game white has two knights black
has a knight in a white squared bishop
and the black spawns pretty much keep
the Knights at bay so let's see what
happens
white trades and rook takes rook takes
is probably better than Queen takes
because you wouldn't want the Queen to
take and then the white work on e one
would be looking at the black Queen this
way
the Queen will not be harassed by the
white rook and the work on e7
conveniently defends the f7 pond
and white could possibly move the Queen
behind the work Queen EA twitch would
pin the white e4 pawn but we'll see what
happens also black and now that the
bishops are traded he will be moving his
knight back to the center of the board
from h7 so that Knight retreat was just
a temporary maneuver to trade bishops
and gain some freedom of movement for
the rest of black's pieces so while
white goes up Queen to C for threatening
Knight takes c6 pawn and the easiest way
for black to defend it is to move the
Queen over one square and it's not just
a defensive move because the black Queen
and Merc are attacking that eforp aw
nuts the e4 pawns adequately protected
by Knight and rook but black cannot
bring more pieces to the attack he can
bring his knight back to f6 or g5 and
attack the pawn and since if you look at
the white rook on e one it's only
defended by the other work on a1 and
black could possibly play d5 attacking
the Queen and that e4 pawn is pentas of
the fact that the Ricka and E one is not
adequately defended at this point so
white takes immediate care of that he
moves the rook up one Square to e 2
knots defended by the two knights in the
Queen and he can bring the other work
over behind the ricany to work to e1
if he chooses to do so and rook black
activates is a a crook from behind the
pawn and now attacks that pawn at b2
that I mentioned earlier and with the
black square bishops gone that pawn is
unprotected so white will probably play
b3 now it's true that weakens the blacks
but it completely blocks the black rook
from coming down the B file and since
there's no black scores bishops on the
board the weak black squares on the
white queen side not a serious problem
they come again look at the computer
after mu 15 the chess engine Komodo
again says zero point zero zero so
Alaska plays b3 that's the best way to
block the rook you wouldn't want to put
the work on a 1 to B 1 then the work
that work would have no future good
moves and that would be a terrible spot
to put a work that's worth five pawns
black advances is cc6 pawn and drives
the night from d4 it's a little bit
double-edged because when that pawn goes
to c5 it opens up the d5 square for the
white knight on c3 when that moves
played the night will be threatening
Knight takes for a check on the other
hand we'll see what Black has in mind to
deal with that threat so white retreats
the knight
oh look at that the bishop comes up and
Spears the Queen and rook on the white
diagonal the bishops protected
adequately by the Queen in work so that
forces the trade of the bishop for the
night and it looks like we're headed for
a drawn a fairly easy drawn endgame
white does Knight takes Queen takes
Queen takes rook takes now the ax white
rook on e 2 needs defending so the King
moves over and now the Black Knight
returns to the center and offers to
trade knights and white has to trade
nights because his pawn on e4 is
threatened by night and
well actually he didn't have to trade
nights white retreated the night to d2
that's better than trading the night it
defends the pawn on e4 what now that the
night has moved from f3
why can reinforce the four pawn with the
move f3 and see how the night on d2
covers the see Foursquare preventing
black from plane the c5 pawn up to c4
and so it's still at even position but
that's probably their spray more chances
for white and black keeping the Knights
on the board if he if white had traded
Knights that would just be a fairly
easily drawn working pawn ending anyway
Kappa blocking retreats us tonight from
g5 now he gets good squares for his
knight he can go to F for our d4 where
he attacks the c2 pond and the e2
tonight so lasker stops that by pawn to
c3
that's it keeps the night from d4 and
it's odd there's nothing really to be
gained if Black Ops is Knight up to F
for the rook just moves up to e3 and
there's no strong follow-up so black is
going to strengthen his central position
by playing the pawn the f6 does a couple
things for black first of all it stops
the move e5 forever well not forever but
for a long time because both the f6 and
d6 pawns are on e5 and the second thing
it does it gives the black king
the f7 square to move up where it
protects the knight and rook so white
moves his knight up to see for now black
moves his Knight to f4 attacking the
rook rook moves up to e3 and the knight
retreats to g6 interesting it looks like
blacks content with trying to trade off
the might the Knights again getting a
drawing or component and it looks like
blacks getting ready to play Knight to
e5 white retreats Knight - D - black
retreats his rook it wasn't really doing
anything on b5 it it's better to help
defend the back rank and maybe go over
to eh behind the other work and await
circumstances the only reason the work
was on b5 was it was up there after
white was able to trade off black was
able to trade off his bishop with Bishop
to b5 the Knight took Queen takes Queen
takes and the RIC ended up there so it
didn't have anything to do up there so a
couple like it just moves it back
white plays g3 taking the f4 square away
from the rook capablanca plays a5 that
will inhibit white from playing b4 and
it might give black the possibility of
playing a4 and if pawn takes pawn white
would have double pawns and black can
probably win it back with rook to e8 so
white stops the possible if by playing a
four stops black play four and you can
see that his knight on D two protects
the b3 pawn adequately but at this point
black has secured his Queen side the
only weakness black is on the Queen side
is that a
upon the only way Y can attack it is
Knight to c4 but he can't play Knight to
c4 because that would leave the bee 3
pawn hanging so anyway it looks it still
looks even so the position still looks
even and black plays Knight to e5 and
that so white drives that away right
away he retreats the Knight to d7 white
brings his king up and black maneuvers
his Knight to b6 now what that does for
black the only way white could threaten
the e5 pawn was play Knight to c4 and
that night on b6 covers the c-4 square
so blacks queen site is secure at this
point and you can see that white really
is not in a position to force the e5
move through so it looks like we're
settling into a position where neither
side has many chances to improve their
position white brings his King up to a
better Square right in the middle of the
board where it protects the e4 pawn
along with the rook and Knight and it
prevents black from playing c4 because
the white knight would just take it and
then the King could take back black play
c6 that covers the d5 square and allows
the the black rooks to communicate on
the first and second ranks with each
other white place is a wreck over
doubling rooks on the e-file black
brings his king up Knight comes up
Knight takes and the King takes
but you can see even though the Kings on
c4 he can't get to b5 or d5 because of
that black pawn on c6 so blacks Queen
side is still secure and you can see the
copper block it knew exactly how to
handle and defend with those double
pawns both Alaska and Capablanca were
considered the premier ending experts of
their of this time period black plays
worked to e6 white tries to break
through 'if I've pawned F takes F takes
now not pawn takes because if black does
pawn takes pawn you see that would
expose his double pause he would there
would be King takes e5 followed by
possibly the c6 pawn at some point so
black has an interesting maneuver he
moves his pawn up giving away the c5
pawn but he gets the b3 pawn instead
in the black work on e6 covers the black
pawn on c6 of the King can't do anything
there
white advances his C pawn allowing the
trade of rooks breaking up the pawn
position black just does pawn takes pawn
but that does protect his rook white
plays rook to e4 black advances the pawn
white attacks the pawn from behind black
plays is a5 pawn up the other work
attacks the pawn so that but that's even
after a white gets that pawn back it
will still be five pawns about five
against four let's see what black comes
up with black counter-attacks he's gonna
lose the c3 pawn so he attacks the h2
pawn white takes this Theory's black
gets the h2 pawn now the White King is a
threatening the a5 pawn but black does
rook to be two King gets the pawn and
accounting pawns there's three against
three but notice that the White King is
trapped on the rook file and black is
going to get a passed pawn on the other
side after g5 and then black gets
counter play with h4 and blacks King is
in a better position perhaps than
White's King
the computer says it's completely even
where it moved 43 and both grandmasters
agreed to a draw so the reason that the
Steinitz defense is not very popular
today is the knock-on is it's rather
passive and usually the best black could
do is get a draw so this is an example
both players played the opening quite
well and black really was only able to
hold the draw by some excellent end
gameplay nowadays the more ma the modern
openings give both sides they're more
complicated in both sides get more
chances due to those complications but
if both sides played the game properly
black should be able to equalize
eventually so this was the a good
lead-in to the rear Lopes now we're
going to open up another another
variation how do I get to the you said
alt-tab yeah so if you go alt-tab this
one just openings basic yeah this one or
this one okay so here's a kappa block
yet the next one i want to do is the
open defense
okay so do I probably need to switch the
source one second all right oh yeah
match like yeah make it yeah I just pull
it over a little bit more okay okay um
and now probably need a jump into yes
really quick and try to find this board
that's the draw that we just went
through yeah let's see if we can find
one oh there it is
is this game Bobby you got the one okay
yeah all we need to do just a little
adjusting yeah well I can do this
I believe is the right amount of fire
something like that I think that looks
looks fine let's see that looks fine
yeah it's a little bit all the right
corners cut off a little bit well this
is this is a few seconds in the past oh
is it okay I think that's good it'll go
back to the let's go back to the game
now all right so it's this one out okay
okay we're ready for the second
variation called the open variation this
variation was a favorite of the old
chess player ciguatera SH who was the
next generation after Steinitz he was
one of Steinitz disciples and tarish was
a german grandmaster he did Alaska had
beaten Steinitz and tarish played Alaska
of match rule championship but was not
able to win Lasker beating but
nevertheless terrorist was in the top 20
players for like 30 years and he wrote a
very good book about just the game of
chess and tarish was able to explain
Steinitz as theories in jest much more
clearly in his book then Steinitz was
able to do steinitz was a brilliant
thinker but his writing style was a
little hard to understand and a lot of
his analysis was split up he he was he
had annotated many games in newspapers
in in england and other places so some
of his theories were spread out
tarish and other young high grandmasters
who came after Steinitz put it all
together in a more cohesive and
understandable form now in doing so
Tarrasch took the favorite parts that he
liked and some of Steinitz is more
controversial difficult ideas kind of
got lost in the translation so that's
kind of an interesting thing but anyway
tarish love this open
fence and we'll get into the difference
between that and what we just went
through so once again here's the
starting point now black plays a six
that forces white to either take the
night which is called the exchange
variation and the black has to take back
with the Queen pawn to open up the Queen
file and why can't win the pawn on e5
because black just plays Queen to d4
attacking the undefended night and the
undefended upon and he the knight
retreats Queen takes pawn check and
white has nothing better trade Queen's
Queen takes Queen King takes Queen
that's a dead draw there's better ways
to play the exchange variation last
correct when he used to play that as
white would play Bishop takes Knight
black would play the D takes e6 then
Alaska would place d4 pawn takes Queen
takes Queen takes Knight takes and
because Alaska was such an ending expert
he could often win that game but it was
considered theoretically a draw
now Bobby Fischer took up the exchange
variation for awhile but he didn't play
Alaska's Queen trade after Bishop takes
Knight Queen for d7 pawn takes c6
Fischer castled and he brought in it
showed how complex it could be but
eventually the grandmasters figured out
how to get even positions against
Fischer's idea also and currently the
exchange raishin is favored by some some
players but most grandmasters seem to
think that
White has better winning chances for the
long run if he keeps his white square
bishop by retreating that Bishop to a4
now one quick note on that move 3 a6
that goes all the way back to 1858
America's first world champion Paul
Morphy was the
first guy who used to play that
regularly and it gives black more
flexibility
the steinitz defense we just looked at
black omits a six and just plays d6 and
gets he can hold the position but as we
said it's cramped and somewhat passive
the a6 move allows black later on to
drive the bishop away from the knight on
c6 with the timely b5 the white Bishop
retreats to b3 work still has the good
diagonal but it's not on the night so
that knight on c6 continues to defend
the e5 pawn so that gives black a lot
more possible resources and
opportunities to mix things up and get
strong counter-attacks the downside to
the maneuver a6 + b5 it does weaken
blacks Queen side pawns and squares
somewhat but it's not considered a
serious handicap it's it's a dynamic the
plusses and minuses of advancing the
pawn offset each other so move for black
starts he counter-attacks brings out
develops the knight attacks the
undefended pawn naturally White's not
going to protect the pawn he just
castles he doesn't have to protect the
pawn if black takes it white will all
can always win the pawn back with a
timely rook to e1 the black knight
retreats and then white gets the e5 pawn
so the open defense white black does
take that e4 pawn and gives up his e5
pawn the reason it's open the pawn
trades trading those Center spawns open
up lots of squares for the Knights rooks
bishops diagonals and squares are opened
up so the position is open the steinitz
variation where you have the pawn chains
it's more clothes
and the most popular opening for black
in this position is simply playing the
bishop in front of the king ee 7 it's
called the closed later on black will
protect the 5 pawn was D 6 and there
won't be so many open lines so it's
somewhat easier for black to defend
White's threats but if black plays
really well he can defend with this open
variation too so it comes down to a
matter of grandmaster choice so anyway
at this point black does take the pawn
and it turns out that even the white
could win the pawn back with wrote the
e1 it's better to open up central lines
by advancing the white pawn to d4 and
where it's going to exchange off that
ePHI pawn and it's not safe for black to
do pawn takes pawn here because at some
point rook to e1 would pin the knight on
e4 to the black King so the best move
for black is to play the b5 move driving
the white bishop back and then play
black places deep on up and protects his
exposed knight on e4 this allows white
to get his pawn back with pawn takes
pawn and it would be inaccurate for
white to take back with the knight that
would ease black's defensive chores by
allowing the knight trade Knight takes
pawn takes and then blacks c7 font is
free to move up if you go to c6 and help
protect the pawn center maybe go c5 and
threat threaten c4 or with a counter
tech on the Queen side so the correct
way to play is d4 takes e5 and white is
going to try to drive that knight on e4
away by bringing his knight to d2 later
on now at this point white is
threatening to win the pawn on d5 so the
old lane
to protect it is Bishop to e6 and Mike I
think the best move here is attributed
to a former world champion Karpov he
plays the night his Queen night to d2 to
get rid of that black knight on e4 right
away now the older way they used to play
it it they used to play c3 here but they
found out that black can get a strong
counter-attack by playing Bishop to c5
and attacking that f2 pawn so Karpov
improvement is to play the night over to
there and then Bishop to c5 doesn't make
much sense because white can trade off
the knight on e4 before he can get too
much too many pieces piling up on white
f2 pawn and in fact the main move for
black is to retreat the knight to c5
where he can if he chooses he can take
the bishop on b3 but actually that's not
going to happen
so the next move for white is to play c3
so you can see carpals improvement was
it's called a finesse they used to play
c3 and then Knight B to d2 but Karpov
found out that he would play the knight
to d2 first and then play c3 and it
turns out that Knight takes bishop
really isn't good for black because
white can do the rook pawn takes Bishop
opening up the a file against the a6
pawn which gives a White's impossible
tacking chances so black doesn't take
the bishop he develops his black square
bishop and prepares to castle
now white retreats his Bishop and he
gets the same position that he would
have wanted had he played the move c3
instead of Knight B to d2 so that's a
small improvement that's called a
finesse in chess now the Grand Master's
I'll tell you what they got there was a
the famous grandmaster Viktor Korchnoi
who play Karpov a match for the World
Championship he used to play this for
black all the time
and they had some very interesting games
and the modern grandmasters have refined
some of courts noise moves that this
gets quite sharp and complicated and
quite interesting so white is number two
player probably in the world Fabiano
corona and black is a very strong
grandmaster Mamet the era of this was us
America versus I sure by Jean so I guess
he's from Azerbaijan was played October
2nd 2018 anyway here's what black plays
is quite at least a very interesting
chess he advances his d5 pawn to d4 it
opens up a diagonal for his bishop on e6
which was blocked by the pawn on d5 so
black is trying to get some more squares
for his pieces before white consolidates
and if white had time he might be able
to plant a knight on d4 and block the d5
pawn so black jumps at the opportunity
to advance the pawn before Wieck and
blockade it anyway White's going to
attack the ball and he brings his knight
over to b3 that opens up the bishop the
white bishop on c1 that diagonal and it
threatens to win the pawn on d4 and it
turns out that black could do pawn takes
pawn and pawn takes pawn
but that pawn position actually favors
white because the c3 pawn covers the d4
square blanket trade Queens within that
would just bring the white rook from f1
to d1 and if he doesn't trade Queens why
don't play Queen the e2 and then bring
one of us rooks to d1 and attack the
black Bishop so pawn takes pawn buy
black really isn't the solution here so
black advances the pawn again and that
forces the white bishop to retreat and
now black takes the knight and the
knight the pawn takes the knight back so
white does have double pawns as be three
pawns attacked by the black bishop on e6
but he has an open a file for his rook
and that's going to pin that black work
down to defending the a6 pawn now it
looks like that black pawn on d3 is the
good candidate to get lost because it's
attacked by Bishop and Queen and it's
hard to defend the pawn it's advanced
from all the other pawns so it has to be
defended by black pieces and as we go
through this opening you'll it's very
clever how black can hold on to the pawn
and not lose it later on he does give up
the pawn but he gets another pawn in
return maintaining an equal position
this gets quite interesting how black is
cleverly defends that pawn so first he
brings his Bishop to f5 that's pretty
straightforward white develops his
Bishop to e3
now what White's planning to do is he's
gonna move that Bishop to d4
which is going to block the black queen
from protecting the pond on d3 and then
White's gonna threaten Bishop takes pawn
on d3 and if a grandmaster if he wins a
pawn can usually win the game so that
appears to be what Carver Juana is
planning to do black hurries up in
castles and white does play Bishop to d4
and the computer says that white is 0.4
4/10 of a pawn a little less than half
upon yes he's maintained his opening
advantage let's put it that way but
black is uh is doing fairly well and as
well within he has a good hopes to
completely equalize position white does
not have a winning position he has to be
one point zero zero or one pawn up or
more to really get good winning chances
okay
now black moves his Queen to d5 and the
Queen is on the b3 punt so if white wins
the d3 pawn black squee know when the b3
pawn so white does Bishop takes pawn
Bishop takes Bishop Queen takes and then
black does Queen takes pawn maintaining
equality so white brings his rook over
to e1 mobilizes his rook protects the e5
pawn and prepares route to e3 piling up
on the d3 pawn so very interesting here
black moves the pawn up it can be taken
by queen and night of course Queen takes
pawn would give up the b3 pawn and
Knight takes pawn what allowed Knight
takes Bishop pawn takes Knight Queen
takes pawn so those aren't good so white
just moves the rook up to e2 and now it
looks like he's threat while he is
threatening
takes D to pawn and then his rook will
be aiming at the black Queen that looks
pretty good so what can black come up to
right now well he trades bishops white
takes with the rook now that relieves
the pressure white had the work on a one
where it was attacking the pawn on e6 so
that pressure is gone and the white work
is behind the pawn it's gonna have to
move so that was a good trade for black
[Music]
so that was a good trade for black and
now black liquidates the bishop white
takes with the night and he threatens to
win that pawn again but now black moves
the other bishop up and protects the
pawn this is extremely clever defense
white plays g3 now his threat is F Ford
driving the bishop back and then he can
take the pawn on d2 black drives the
knight back
hold on a second I lost my spot
there we go
all right let's see where was I
okay
so the black bishop is defending the
pawn and white threatens f4 black drives
the knight back the knight goes up see
how the night is undefended the Queen
comes up attacks the night the night
goes to d6 now the Queen retreats and
you can see that if white were to play
f4 now
black would just take Bishop takes a
fork because the pawn on g3 is pinned by
the black Queen that's very clever
defensive play so white advances his h4
pawn to make the bishop move and we're
about out of time so we're gonna wrap it
up soon at this point black makes an
inaccuracy and plays Bishop to f4 and
the pawn can't take it but what black
should have done had he pull he could
have won the pawn on h4 with Bishop
takes pawn
then white would win the pawn on d2 but
black could activate his rook to d8
White has nothing better than the trade
Queens look at the white works they're
they're not active now the black Bishop
retreats hitting the knight the knight
retreats now f5 hits the knight pawn
takes pawn takes King up f5 Knight back
Bishop to f6 and we've reached a
completely even ending there's five
white pawns and five black pawns and the
white rooks are in bad shape but he'll
be able to in a few moves exchange some
works he'll play Knight to f3 perhaps
and rook to d2 and then it'll just be
Knight and work versus Rick and Bishop
but this is going to be a drawn ending
black does have a weak pawn on f5 it's
not it can't be protected by any other
pawn black's pawn on e6 is a little weak
too but with the reduced material it
won't be hard for the black works to
defend the position so we'll let it go
here
thanks for coming
[Music]